j'admire beaucoup et j'ai toujours
admiré grimaud et je n'ai jamais eu de
style it et personnelle contre
cohn-bendit
après tout quand il a voulu revenir en
france il m'a donné un coup de téléphone
et m'a demandé que j'obtienne de
l'elysée l'autorisation de revenir en
france et j'ai fait de son mieux et on
m'a donné la promesse qu après quelques
semaines ou quelques mois ils
reviendraient alors je pense aussi que
le carnaval et c'est dans toutes les
sociétés
mais je crois même l'avoir écrit dans la
la révolution introuvable le carnaval
fait partie des sociétés
c'est le moment où tout est bouleversé
où les étudiants deviennent des
professeures et des professeurs des
étudiants ou les rôles se renverse et
ainsi de suite
et de ce point de vue bien sûr je
préfère de beaucoup un psychodrame une
révolution mais il y a deux choses
j'avais été le critique le plus sévère
de l'ancienne université mais j'ai été
humilié pour l'université par la manière
dont l'ancien d'université a été
détruite
c'était tout de même très dur pour les
vieux professeur qui était respectable
et qui ont été souvent traitée d'une
manière impossible
alors quand j'ai été en apparence de
leur côté c'est parce qu'à ce moment là
ils étaient les humilier et je ne
voulais pas être du côté des
révolutionnaires contre les professeurs
et encore aujourd'hui je ne le regrette
pas et j'ai toujours pensé que votre
réaction en mai 68 qui nous a surpris
beaucoup de gens et qu'ils doivent bien
sûr parce que j'ai des critiques de
l'ancienne université
j'ai toujours mis en relation vous aime
dire si city view pas avec ce qui est
aussi la scène primitive pour raymond
aron c'est à dire sa connaissance de
l'allemagne en 1930 1933 tu m'expliques
d'ailleurs un pays quitte une
civilisation extraordinairement une
culture extraordinairement riche d'avant
garde avec une tendance à
l'irrationalisme dans beaucoup de
domaines
enfin vous le savez ça mieux que moi et
c'est irrationalisme cette culture
décadente entre guillemets se termine
commencé c'est-à-dire dans le nazisme
avez-vous pensé à cela 68 un petit peu
mais il y avait quelque chose d'autre
qui était si je puis dire ma part de
gaullisme je ne pouvais pas accepter que
le général de gaulle fut renversé par
cohn-bendit
c'était pour moi une humiliation
nationale et ce qui était inacceptable
ce n'est pas les manifestations
universitaires
c'était la transformation de ces
troubles en révolution or après tout
mitterrand annoncé déjà sa candidature à
la présidence de la république et
mendès-france organiser un gouvernement
transitoire
c'est à dire qu'il oubliait d'un coup
qui avait une constitution de la vème
république qui prévoyait dans le cas de
la défie la démission du président de la
république le processus constitutionnel
légal pour arriver à un nouveau
président à un public
gt gt pas tellement furieux contre le
psychodrame
j'ai été juste été très furieux contre
la révolution une révolution ou l'ont
renversé une constitution parce que les
étudiants avaient le désir de se
distraire et de pas la vraie
indéfiniment là je n'ai rien contre les
pats la dre conditions de prêt de dans
la pseudo révolution présente toujours
un risque de dérapage en même temps donc
on peut dire que 1958 qui avait ramené
le général de gaulle au pouvoir était
aussi une pseudo révolution mêmes
c'était presque un coup d'état militaire
qui a été ratifiée en scène par le par
le sucre sel mais tout de même bon
lire juste un mot à propos de ce que
disait jacques hubert tout à l'heure je
crois que c'est tout de même vrai que
cette expérience vous a marqué seulement
elle pas fait puisque vous n'écrivez pas
dans vos mémoires mais ailleurs qui a vu
la montée au pouvoir de hitler de
staline c'est qu'il faut s'attendre au
pire souvenir de cette phrase qu'il faut
redouter le pire il faut redouter le
pire
et je crois que c'est aussi une réponse
peut-être à ce que vous disais ça
pourquoi as tu eu si peur de déconner le
siècle a donné quelques justifications
mabri évidence tout de même il ya des
arguments très très plus proche en
italie par exemple ça a commencé comme
en france et ça a continué avec le
terrorisme en france il s'est passé
quelque chose de merveilleux
c'est à dire que les garçons de 68 on
complique un moment donné s'ils
continuaient
ils deviendraient des fascistes alors
cela ils sont devenus des vrais libéraux
ils ont ils ont le goût de la révolte
contre la réalité mais ils savent qu'à
partir d'un certain moment quand on dit
élection trahison c'est on met en
question les fondements mêmes de nos
libertés ça ils l'ont compris c'était
pas évident en mai 68
amour non le chapitre sur mai 68
je n'ai pas pris position pour moi ni
contre moi mais je trouve que j'ai donné
toutes les opinions à travers des
citations et des commentaires et je
trouve que vous avez tort de dire que
mai 68
enfin vous
donner une alternative révolution au
carnaval il ya une part de carnaval et
nous sommes tous pour le carnaval c'est
très bien mais il me semble que la
fécondité hills et je suis 10 et 12
points sociologue ça n'est pas
l'imagination social qui est votre une
femme ma force parce que sinon c'est pas
10 ans espace qui vous intéresse le lire
on est bien il me semble que dans le
langage de touraine je crois c'est ce
qu'on pourrait appeler un mouvement
social est tout de même jusqu'à inventer
1068 sait beaucoup de choses sur
lesquelles nous vivons y compris le
politique
je crois que nous serions assez d'accord
pour dire qu'une épouvantable stérilité
des institutions politiques à recréer il
faut bien créer continuellement la
société or mai 68 est venu main parce
que le l'ensemble des institutions et
être incapable de se recréer vous l'avez
très bien montré à propos de
l'université on pourra le dire de la
politique on pourrait le dire de de
l'usiné on peut dire beaucoup de choses
fausses ensuite je ne lui est pas une
vous n'avez pas le désir que je réponds
si si et seulement si l'asie mais ça ne
devrait pas pour relancer
non non on l'a pas l'émission je dirais
simplement que les semaines de mai comme
toujours comporte bilan positif et
négatif il y a un bilan positif
c'est-à-dire la diffusion à travers le
pays d'un certain nombre de thèmes de
révolte contre la société industrielle
ces thèmes je les connaissais vous les
connaissiez je les avais développer dans
les désillusions du progrès mais les
jeunes gens ont rendu populaire des
thèmes qui auparavant était réservé à
des gens sérieux et cela il était gay is
était drôle et par conséquent ils ont
fait quelque chose de bien
d'un autre côté il y à un négatif c'est
à dire que l'université ne s'est pas
encore remise d
événements de mai 68 je ne suis que
partiellement un universitaire mais je
pense que les nations besoin d'une
université et que dans les universités
il ne faut pas abuser de la politique
pour les deux ou trois minutes qui nous
reste